[Música]
hace algunas semanas leí una nota en un
medio nacional que se titulaba los
romeritos y los guasones peligran por
bajo consumo la nota me llamó mucho la
atención esta nota se escribió en el
centro de la república para lo mismo
sucede aquí en nuestra región ahora este
del país en el noreste de méxico y para
ponerlos un poquito en contexto me
gustaría que levanten la mano quién de
ustedes consume habitualmente chochas
mezquites jakub smagua catas pueden
levantar la mano
al juego en cubero un 30% ahora la
pregunta es dejen la mano arriba por
favor de los que levantaron la mano
quien mayor de 20 o sea los mayores de
25 años por favor baje en la mano
es sorprendente y esto era un poquito
para ponerlos en contexto de la
importancia de la plática de hoy y cuál
es el mensaje es hacer conciencia
gastronómica cómo hacemos conciencia
gastronómica hoy en día los habitantes
de esta ciudad y sobre todo los niños y
jóvenes probablemente estén más
familiarizados con las hamburguesas las
pizzas los hot dogs aquí en victoria las
bone des que es un fenómeno
y así los hábitos alimenticios han
cambiado drásticamente en los últimos
años hoy en día lo que antes pues era
parte de nuestra comida habitual y parte
de nuestra canasta básica los productos
que consumimos y que producen nuestra
tierra hoy en día han perdido muchísima
popularidad y es ahí donde este concepto
de conciencia gastronómica cobra tanta
importancia
y conciencia gastronómica se basa en dos
factores fundamentales por un lado la
conciencia cultural la responsabilidad
cultural que tenemos todos nosotros y la
responsabilidad social y esto nos
incluye a todos porque tiene que ver con
nuestros hábitos alimenticios con
nuestros hábitos de consumo hablar de
cultura y de responsabilidad cultural
tiene que ver por un lado y para esto
tenemos que entender que es cultura el
concepto de cultura cultura es un todo y
es un todo que engloba a nuestra
historia que engloba a nuestras raíces
nuestras tradiciones nuestras costumbres
la cultura es quiénes somos y quiénes
somos nosotros
y para hacer otro ejercicio me gustaría
que levantaran la mano quien me puede
dar un ejemplo sin mencionar que aquí en
victoria las pautas son de harina y sin
mencionar las gorditas doña tota que no
puede dar un ejemplo de un platillo
típico de aquí de ciudad victoria sí por
levantar la mano
esa es la importancia de la plática y es
por eso que es tan importante dejar esa
semilla en cada uno de ustedes
la gastronomía mexicana hoy en día desde
el 2010 es patrimonio de la humanidad
por múltiples razones por su historia
por su continuidad pero sobre todo
porque en méxico la gastronomía no tiene
clases sociales yo puedo ir echarme unos
tacos con mis amigos y a lo mejor la
persona más rica de méxico también hace
lo mismo en mexico
esos sabores auténticos y esos sabores
de manos hechas con tu amor no los
encontramos en los mejores restaurantes
del mundo no los encontramos en los
mejores restaurantes de mexico ojo los
mejores restaurantes de méxico hoy en
día a nivel nacional y a nivel mundial
han hecho que el mundo voltea a vernos y
voltear nuestra gastronomía el esfuerzo
que está haciendo enrique olvera el
esfuerzo que está haciendo jorge vallejo
el esfuerzo que está haciendo otros
grandes con grandes restaurantes
pioneros en la nueva cocina mexicana han
hecho que el mundo voltea a vernos sin
embargo
aquel asado que hace doña chonita en su
fogón con su olla de barro con esas
manos que tienen 40 años preparándolo no
lo vamos a encontrar ningún otro lado en
el mundo es por eso que nuestra
identidad gastronómica es parte
fundamental de quiénes somos y es
orgullo de nosotros los mexicanos como
ejemplo si por ejemplo yo le pregunto un
poblano que me diga un platillo típico
de su región yo creo que hasta muchos de
aquí pueden dar esa respuesta no creo
que la gastronomía poblana es inmensa y
tiene muchos platillos típicos pues
muchos de nosotros conocemos el mole
poblano entonces es la importancia de
esta plática que el día de mañana puedan
preguntarte hoy cuál es un platillo
típico de tu región y puedas contestar
lo que puedas contestar varias opciones
y así paso a lo que viene siendo la
responsabilidad social y esa
responsabilidad social tiene que ver con
nuestro entorno y nuestra comunidad que
estamos haciendo nosotros en el día a
día para apoyar a todas aquellas
personas
pues que es la parte a 40 grados e ir a
la sauna y alomejor se pican con
las hojas de la palma y la baja me
llegan y la venden y se dan cuenta pues
que ya no se consume ya no hay mercado
que estamos haciendo nosotros para poder
dignificar el trabajo de todas aquellas
personas de todas esas manos
de todas esas recetas que se están
perdiendo hoy en día que estamos
haciendo nosotros como comunidad que
estamos haciendo nosotros como
victorenses que estamos haciendo como
tamaulipecos
y así esta responsabilidad y
responsabilidad social y esta
responsabilidad cultural tienen que ver
con todos nosotros y probablemente
algunos de ustedes estarán preguntándose
y por qué me está hablando de cocina
regional y de productos regionales un
chef de un restaurante de cocina
asiática
y es allí donde
y es ahí donde vengo a platicarles un
poquito de lo que hacemos y de esta
responsabilidad de cómo vivimos esta
filosofía de vida cuando yo y mi socio
decidimos ampliar el restaurante tomamos
esa decisión de aportar ese granito de
arena para poder contribuir aunque sea
un poquito con todas esas personas que
son las verdaderas manos y los
verdaderos artistas de la gastronomía
regional entonces lo que hicimos fue
empezar a trabajar con productos
regionales y con ingredientes regionales
obviamente con una limitante que es por
un lado pues que somos un restaurante de
cocina asiática entonces qué hacemos a
través de técnicas orientales buscar
implementar productos regionales y es
así como empezamos cada fin de semana a
implementar los productos regionales que
tenemos de temporada y empezamos a
trabajar con jaiba lo que buscamos
también es que todos estos productos
buscar la mejor versión de ellos
entonces en este caso como pueden ver en
medio lo que parece cambiar es un falso
caviar de chile piquín que buscábamos
con el chile piquín que tuviera ese
sabor tan exquisito que tiene pero bajar
un poquito ese punto de picor entonces
trabajamos con jaivas trabajamos con
piquín es
trabajamos con langostinos este este
plato precisamente que se llaman y
guiris del río frío es un plato que te
invita a ir y a conocer la bocatoma es
un plato que te habla de esa experiencia
de irte como no nos dan los tinos a la
orilla del río frío y luego comerte un
delicioso mango para bajar un poquito de
intensidad de sabores de lo que probaste
entonces lo que buscamos es precisamente
que salgas y que conozcas y que vayas a
ese lugar a lo mejor con lo que hacemos
y con los especiales que vendemos cada
fin de semana no vamos a hacer que
subsisten algunas comunidades rurales
pero sí vamos a hacer que a ti te entre
esa semillita y te entre esa cosquillita
por consumir estos productos que veas
esta presentación y digas oye yo quiero
consumirlo yo quiero trabajar con él
quiero probar porque a lo mejor nunca lo
habías probado pero lo probaste y
dijiste bueno quiero incluirlo en mi
canasta básica y así trabajamos con
maguaca estás con catán este plato se
llama que tan bajo la sombra de una mano
porque te invita a ir a la presa vicente
guerrero a disfrutar en la sombra de un
ébano de todos estos manjares
que tiene esta región para ofrecernos
trabajamos con chochas trabajamos con
mezquite trabajamos con los sabores que
tenemos aquí en nuestra tierra este es
un plato que te habla de los sabores de
la caída algo con los que todos crecimos
el elote asado el mango
este plato precisamente viene en un
huevo porque representa el origen el
origen de nuestros sabores con los que
todos crecimos trabajamos con distintas
cactáceas este plato se llama yendo tula
jaumave porque trabajamos con todos esos
frutos de las cactáceas que están en
este tramo de tula jaumave que es una
zona árida trabajamos con lana cahuita
que antes se usaba para remedios de la
tos que antes se usaba para curar
enfermedades respiratorias hoy en día es
muy difícilmente se conoce están acá
agüita la calificamos y luego lo que
hicimos la rellenamos con un piñón gran
piña dow entonces lo que ustedes pueden
pensar que es el fruto tal cual
realmente llevó un proceso de trabajo
para ese producto poder presentarlo
de la mejor versión y que ustedes lo
puedan degustar y digan oye lo tengo
enfrente de mi casa nos decía un cliente
y el juego como si fueran canicas con
este con lassana cagüitas trabajamos con
el anca de rana que un platillo muy
popular en matamoros trabajamos con el
cabrito y el machito que son sabores muy
de la región o obviamente a través de
esta técnica oriental que es el vago si
trabajamos con la paloma de ala blanca y
trabajamos con todos esos productos que
tiene nuestra tierra para ofrecer
presentándolos a través de técnicas
orientales y esto con qué fin por un
lado si nosotros como restaurante
queremos tener los productos de mejor
calidad
no podemos tener mejor calidad que lo
que tiene nuestra tierra ofrecernos
entonces por eso lo que hay de temporada
buscamos trabajar con él de alguna u
otra forma buscamos de popularizarlo y
que todos ustedes quieran volver a
consumirlo
porque presentamos unos nigiris de
tamaulipas porque si yo quisiera ponerme
hacer nigiris como los hacen en tokio en
donde entra el marisco o armen el mar
pues jamás tendría éxito sin embargo si
yo interpreto mis sabores y lo que yo
conozco a través de técnicas orientales
probablemente venga un japonés lo pruebe
y diga no es como lo que conozco no es
mejor ni peor pero es muy de aquí y es
muy de la región entonces ahí es donde
entra la autenticidad la autenticidad de
tener una cocina genuina
y cuál es el fin de todo esto cuál es el
objetivo de esta plática el objetivo de
todo esto es que ustedes salgan que
prueben que disfrutan lo que tiene
nuestra tierra para ofrecer que conozcan
su estado que conozcan su tierra que
conozcan los productos que tenemos aquí
a nuestro alcance que recuperemos el
orgullo colectivo de vivir en esta gran
nación y si el día de mañana el
restaurante doña vicky está lleno porque
prepara unas cosas bien buenas y decide
gente de otro país o de otro estado
venir a ciudad victoria meramente a
probar estos platillos creo que el
esfuerzo mío es mucha otra gente que
buscamos recuperar ese orgullo colectivo
valió la pena muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]
e